so i borrowed an outfit from jc penney's
kept the tags on and uh took the bus
downtown chicago and went to this agency
and i sat down
and uh she said i brought you in here
just to help you out by telling you
you'll never
make it in this business you should just
become a bartender
i really hope you remember her name i do
and i sent her a cover of me and the
rolling stone
two years later my god
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that
happen i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
today on the show is the beautiful jenny
mccarthy
so jenny and i are probably
sisters from another mister in another
life or perhaps another galaxy as you'll
learn in this episode
we have from like very early on just
doing her doing interviews for her show
um when we would meet at the sirius xm
studio
we really connected very quickly on
consciousness and extraterrestrial
and energy and just
all of the things in life that for me
are
my daily content of what i read about
what i'm learning about what i watch on
youtube
shows that i like watching documentaries
that i like watching
um so she kind of takes us on this
really really really fun roller coaster
ride from being
a kid that grew up grew up outside
chicago um like myself
and uh and then getting to the point
that she is now with
um her curiosities um but the lessons
that she learned along the way
and the challenges that she had and um
you are 100 gonna laugh your ass off um
i did and uh you're also going to fall
in love with jenny because she
if you haven't already because she's um
truly
a a well-rounded person
she is smart she is curious she is
beautiful she is determined she is
wise and uh you're going to figure that
all out in this episode so
i hope you enjoy the show hi pretty girl
hi beautiful i love your shirt for those
who are only listening
tell everyone what it says uh life is
short
don't be a dick
know my son was just my son was just
upstairs and he goes
um your shirt's a little inappropriate i
go
but true he goes you're right
what made you like what what's going on
today that you're like today's the [ __ ]
day i'm gonna put this shirt on you know
what it was the only thing that was
clean
in my t-shirt drawer so there was no
purpose but that a good enough reason
um so we're both like chicago girls i'm
just gonna call us chicago girls even
though
we were kind of born and raised a little
outside of chicago we don't want to
bother people with those silly details
so what do you think it is that makes
us girls from that area so great you
know i gotta
tell you because being i after living in
la then for 20 years
i would always figure out energetically
like somebody i liked and then they
happened to be from chicago and i'm like
of course
like i fell in love with you and i
didn't find out
realize until after the fact i'm like oh
my god i don't know if
that's why but i do believe that
there's something homegrown
and grounding in the midwest and not to
offend anybody else on the coasts
but there's just i don't know there's
just something
that feels real
it feels it feels like when i lived in
l.a
and i came back here to visit my mom
when i was in my 20s i'd be like ew
gross you guys are all so behind on
trends
you know me in my 20s and as i got older
every time i go back to chicago i feel
like this sense of like
peace or if i you know went to michigan
or in indiana or anywhere it's just
i think it's just more of a moral
grounding maybe yeah i
i mean i i'm i'm obviously isolating you
know chicago but um but it's really the
midwest
i mean i feel like whenever you're out
and about and you like someone's
friendly and they're nice and you're
like huh where are you from and they go
inevitably
michigan right that's for indiana
wisconsin and you're like oh
got it yep makes perfect sense now
that's why
so maybe maybe it's maybe it's then
worth like talking about childhood
like what is it that crafts like what is
it about the midwest maybe we're
we're gonna you know there's country
songs made up made about flyover states
and all but like
maybe somebody would be like you know
what that sounds like a great place to
live
or maybe we're just going to tell silly
ridiculous stories about being drunk in
corn fields i'm not really sure
but but like what is what was high
school like what's a party like in high
school
where you grew up um you know
what what i feel like i'll back it up
even more because i remember
um you know having all the neighbors sit
on their porch
drinking beers hard-working people blue
collar
you know my dad was a steel worker and
my mom was a stay-at-home mom but was
also a hairdresser so she cut everyone's
hair in the neighborhood
so she could feed us dinner um and i
just saw this like
pride proudness hard working
but also knowing how to enjoy life and
the family unit you know it's just
it's just not the same anymore and
catching lightning bugs
um you know just being able to walk
anywhere to the dime store um playing
sports
always having like your parents there um
and then by the time
teenage world came up it was you know i
went to an all-girl catholic school
did you really that yeah i'm just
kidding
that explains a lot what happened in
college when i got there and i was like
let me try that acid and that mushroom
and all that stuff
we're already on high school so we're
almost there right
high school was tough though for me to
high school i feel like was
my uh kindergarten
into into hollywood because it was
an all-girls school they were rich i had
we didn't have any money so my dad
started working three jobs to put us
through catholic school
and so there was a lot of bullying a lot
of like um
what is that movie pretty in pink is
that the name of it where she molly
ringwald just like
couldn't get a prom dress and the girls
made fun of her
so i had a lot of problems like my hair
was lit on fire
girls would wait for me after school to
beat me up with pipes
what and yeah back it up back it up
they waited for you to beat you up with
pipes yeah
yeah it was good it was bad i remember
what happened
yeah um i was walking home from school
and a girl um from a neighboring high
school
said that i looked at her boyfriend i'm
like
i don't even know what you're talking
about and uh
they followed me all the way home and
then my mom
and dad came out and uh gave them a
piece or two my dad actually threw one
of them down the stairs
so it's nice to have my dad have my back
you know but it was
it was it was a tough time but i
feel like it gave me some armor gave me
the
armor that i needed to when i went out
to hollywood
and critics um clicks
uh i was able to manage
myself through that i think because of
what i went through in high school
why catholic school like what what why
was it a bad school district so that was
like the best option because that can
happen in areas
my mom's gonna be so good for jenny
we're gonna send her
and wait how many brothers sisters what
do you have i have three sisters
what three sisters four girls
four girls in our house so my my parents
um
they my mom was very religious very
catholic okay well there it is
yeah so she was like you're gonna burn
in hell if you don't go to catholic
school
her belief system but then college came
and i was what did you go to
i went to college i went in for
um special ed i want to be a special ed
teacher ironically
and then my one of the first classes i
had to take was public speaking
and i couldn't do public speaking i
literally would
throw up so i was in the class and they
called on me and i ran right out of the
room
went down to my i don't know what you
call it aid counselor whatever you call
it
and said i i can't i can't take public
speaking i can't she's like
do you want to change your major i was
like yeah
um does nursing have public speaking
and she said no so i changed my major to
nursing
but i only made it two years because i
went broke
so almost there i know wait hang on we
gotta talk about
your mushrooms and acid in college you
have to
do you feel like you got that out of
your system like was it crazy like do
you have a crazy college story
uh i have so many can't come crazy where
do i [ __ ] start
yeah here we go i didn't i have a ged i
didn't even finish high school i didn't
even go to like a
you know graduation yeah but look at the
most successful people
don't so you're in with a good crowd so
i
um i went there and we didn't have much
money at all
so um i started
by selling weed uh i would sell
like shake so anyone that had leftovers
[ __ ] in their bags
i would put it all together and i would
sell literally shake
for food then i would also
flirt with guys in a bar to go home with
them
yeah and i'd be like why don't you go in
your bedroom and i'll meet you there and
then i'd go to the
refrigerator and i would steal the food
out of their fridge
and take it home and that's how i
literally like did you like leave with
the food and leave them high and dry
probably had winton's bedroom i stole
all the frozen pizzas and stuff out of
the
and it it it only gets worse too but um
then it's so resourceful a very
very and i then started getting besides
smoking the wheat someone was like why
don't we try acid
and i'm like all right expand my mind
that sounds so interesting
that would be the door that opened for
me
where i would then eventually for the
rest of my life
be interested in everything with
consciousness
ethereal just mind expanding and
my acid trips were so
amazing like i got so good at it
too good at it that i created
an acid tour in college
yes as a business or like as in like
take acid and i'm going to give you the
best trip ever and this is what we're
going for
yep so i get like 20 people signed up
and i was like a shaman of acid
and i would take people on this because
i was at southern illinois university so
there's a lot of plush greenery and
i would take them out for 12 hours give
them amazing experiences
and and then do like weird things like
read them like i had the ability to be
like this is what you need to work on
oh yeah you're doing you like going
going into the consciousness of your
of your friends and giving them like uh
uh you know psychic advice
totally but some people don't even know
do you still do these tours by any means
at all you know what's so funny i would
love
to do another one like i'm like donnie
has never my husband's never done drugs
this is really weird for rockstar you
know what i mean yeah and i was like i
kind of miss
you know taking acid he's like what no
don't be ridiculous and i'm like no i
actually really kind of not on a regular
basis but maybe like once around nature
because this is the thing about acid and
when i
like i had dinner with eckhart tolle and
i asked him about it
which is he took acid
and he's like i want to experience what
it was like so many people were talking
to me about it
and i was like oh my god what is eckhart
tolle like on acid
and he said it's kind of
weirdly enough the place where i am now
you are present
with everything you literally are
so in the present moment and every
single thing
is like it's a miracle you're becoming
one with everything it's like a tree you
can stare at for like
eight hours because you're literally
becoming one with the tree
and now not all people have this
experience if you have
bad [ __ ] going on in your life that will
kind of come up that in setting right
jenny you got to set and setting them
that's why you give them the tour
that's why you got to set them up you're
like look we're going to sit here we're
going to like get quiet we're going to
breathe we're in nature
it's always important with those plant
medicines or varieties
that's what i'm like when people go up
and take that tea and stuff i'm like
uh you better be in a good place even
though they go up there to bring up
the old stuff and to work on their
shadows
in ayahuasca yes that's what i mean yep
but i i don't really want to try that
for some reason
i'm not interested but i would go for a
good shroom
or a good acid and uh just
even in my backyard i'd be like oh yeah
but i guess the goal though is to
become present without the help of acid
you know what i mean so you've heard the
did you read the ramdas
like that's kind of the rhonda story wow
you're
um a be here now book it's a really cool
book i mean it has like lots of pictures
and
you know if you follow ramdas on social
media or something like that they'll
post like pictures that have
so it's a very different kind of book
but at the beginning is the whole story
about how he was
i'm gonna paraphrase and probably make a
few mistakes here but
basically he was like a professor and
then he kind of then there was like a
sort of
testing on of lsd and he got into the
state that he just loved and so then it
kind of became a thing and then him and
his
like someone that he worked with would
do it all the time then at one point in
time they decided they want to be on lsd
for
for three weeks straight so they like
had it all timed out and then anyway
work kind of fell apart i think he
didn't really even want to do it anymore
because he wasn't finding joy so then he
goes over to
um india i suppose or somewhere like
that and he
is you know drudging around with his
buddy that you know he
did lsd for three three weeks with and
plenty of other times i'm sure
and he wanted to kind of like understand
life and
how do i get to that state that i'm in
when i'm on it all the time
and so he he as he's going through
like you know he's there for a long time
and um
comes across this um this guru or shaman
of some sort
and he gives him like
a triple hit of lsd and nothing happens
and he gives him another triple hit i'm
pretty sure it's a triple hit and then
another triple hit so essentially it
should be like
nine giant doses of lsd and
he was unaffected
wow and so that was i think because he
was just so in that state
like he was already at that frequency
of existence where he so i think again
i'm probably making some mistakes and
somebody might
criticize my like paraphrasing that i
read this a couple of years ago in his
book but
um yeah but that's kind of basically the
the ramdas story is like him
realizing that like you can achieve this
state in a different way and i think he
actually
didn't do it as much after that um but
anyway
it's true though because that's i got to
a place where i'm like
okay i'm done you know i did probably
over a hundred hits
in my tour guiding career um
so the fact that he was able to take
that much and he doesn't have brain
damage
makes me that's the good part of the
feels so good
well now we're back to weekly tours
jenny's weekly tours
this is such a good business transition
it's so with
nature it's with one you got you know it
was it was it was
awesome because it made me it like i
said it opened the door for what was to
come next
but what started happening was
i was giving them starting to give them
free because
i felt like it was helping people so i
so then i was like okay i gotta come up
with a new business
so um this is where the story gets
this is the crescendo of my college
story so
i went to my um
i lived i lived in an apartment building
and i asked the administrator there
do you guys need any part-time work and
they were like yeah actually we do
so i started working there i'm like i am
not going to pay my bills
with making this rate so
i saw like a printer there and these
like
stickers and i was like what if i
make parking passes like vip
parking passes and i sell them to
freshmen it's like a real [ __ ]
but um i was desperate i was totally
desperate so
i printed out all these vip parking
passes
and started selling him the freshman and
it was i had like three thousand dollars
i'm like
this is awesome so i was like able to
buy my books
i was almost get kicked out of school
because i couldn't pay for it
and i'm in my apartment in my bedroom
and there's a knock on my bedroom door
and my
three roommates open the door and
they're like this i'm like what
what's wrong who died and they're like
there's two police at the door to arrest
you
i was like what what
i'm like did someone say i was selling
weed they're like no
did you did you like was it
was it the acid and then i was like was
it my bounce jacks
because i would bounce checks everywhere
on campus for two dollars for chinese
food
so so then um i said okay
stall just go talk to them and tell them
i'm getting out of the shower i'm gonna
jump out of the window
it was a two-story building i jumped out
of the window
ran to my car and never
went back what never went back
you escaped you left all your [ __ ] there
left all my [ __ ] there and was like oh
well
drove six hours home went back with my
mom and dad and they're like
what are you doing i'm like i couldn't
afford school and that rule was really
the truth of it
i tried really hard any which way and
they're like all right and
i felt like such a loser
going back home i was like running from
police
i'm like what the hell am i supposed to
do now
you're like mike my religious mother's
going to be
so mad pray for me mom
right great for me so i remember just
laying on my water bed
water bed oh my god you had one too my
mom and dad had one and my sister had
one oh my god those were the best and
weird
they put you to sleep so quick
i i remember just laying there being
like super depressed
like literally what am i gonna [ __ ]
do with my
life and then i kind of just
went inward and said is there anything
else you'd like to do
and you know ever since i was little i
would try to like make movies or
interview like i'd set up my basement
chairs everywhere
and pretend to be oprah and interview
the neighbors and
make these little videos and i'm like
well maybe i can like try
my hand at like tv or modeling
so um i didn't tell anyone this because
i was like they're gonna tell me
don't be ridiculous it will never happen
for you so i took a polaroid
camera and i went outside by my garage
and i literally took like
70 selfies why my garage is because the
only thing that was a white
backdrop so i took 70
polaroids right and i hope you got to
get the you got to get the film back
before you can actually pick one that
looks good remember back in the day when
you can't we got so excited
you were in your car like looking at
them after you okay got it yep so you
found totally
probably 69 that we're good
if that um so then i took the yellow
pages
yellow pages millennials are probably
like what um and i opened it up to
commercial agencies
and i put each one in an envelope and i
mailed 70 of them out and i just
waited and thought well if i hear back
great if i don't then there's my
trajectory you know and i got one
letter back that said we'd love to meet
with you downtown chicago
and uh come meet us so i
borrowed an outfit from jc penney's kept
the tags on
and took the bus downtown chicago
and went to this agency and i sat down
and uh she said i brought you in here
just to help you out by telling you
you'll never
make it in this business you should just
become a bartender
i'm gonna save you a lifetime of like
hell by trying to go down this route and
i was like
got it oh my god i really hope you
remember her name
i do and i sent her a cover of me and
the rolling stone
two years later my god
the satisfaction in that
you know yeah and you know i think there
is app
and we've heard this before people that
tell you no or you can't do anything or
you can't do it
that always gave me drive like always it
fuels me to this day if people say
you'll never be able to do that then i'm
like oh really just watch me
so um that was the end of and that
wasn't the end of the story i left her
building and was on the curb crying
like [ __ ] and
after i was done crying i kind of looked
up and across the street was the playboy
building and i was like
oh don't do that your mom will
kill you my mom's mother teresa
i have four aunts that are nuns six
uncles that are priests it's like
we're like the vatican mccarthy's
so i found myself walking across the
street saying myself
let me just ask the secretary a question
so i took the elevator up and i went to
the lady considering i was wearing this
jc penny outfit i was borrowing why
doesn't
why not get you know more use out of it
so i go to her and i say how do
how do girls become playmates and she
said not by walking in
they send in a photo of themself in a
bikini
and we get about a million pictures a
year so
take a picture and send it in and i said
okay turn around press the elevator
button and i'm waiting
waiting and this guy walks past
and he said are you inquiring about
being a playmate
i said yes
because i still wasn't sure and he said
you know we have a
photo shoot happening right now if you
feel comfortable putting a bikini on
and just taking a a quick picture and we
can send it to half
and i'm thinking to myself a million
miles an hour did i
shave yeah like
i wasn't prepared so and by the way
back then in the early 90s no one was
shaving their moss
at least i wasn't in the midwest i
didn't know anyone even trimmed it so it
was like
cool so i go
in the back and i put him in this bikini
and i'm in
this playboy studio and i'm like how the
[ __ ] did this happen
destiny maybe i don't know so i go to
the go on set
and the photographer's like okay to
stand there and um you know strike a
pose
and i literally i'm so stiff i do a mug
shot
i literally go stand forward and then i
do a profile
and smile and that's all i could give
them because
and i'm in a bikini and your muff is
coming out the sides
so i take the city bus back home which
was like an hour drive
and when i got home my little answering
machine
said hi we want to officially test you
for miss october
i was like oh am i kidding
[Music]
this is on the same day like i go
downtown this lady denies me
and then i see that the play
it's a playboy thing had to be it was
literally across the street like
weird serendipity weird so
i sat there for a second going i don't
know if i can do this because i have to
sell my soul to the devil because i too
was in the belief system
that i was going to burn in hell if i
did this
and um i was like well
i have nowhere else to no other
direction
maybe this will get me to hollywood and
open some doors
and i did it i did it and it was
terrifying
and scary and i almost didn't make it
because they said i had the worst
expressions they've ever seen on a
playmate
because i look terrified they're like
you look like you're watching a murder
is it your first ever photo shoot first
ever photo shoot
no [ __ ] yep you know how many of the
girls are so angry because they've
probably done a million and they're like
i just want to be playmate like i'm a
professional
and you're like so i look like i was
doing a mug shot
and it's my friend i will say this about
playboy though is their goal is to like
find
the girl next door you know and i was
really the girl next door
like i had one [ __ ] unibrow i've
never even plucked an eyebrow it was
just
so crazy so they gave me one more day
they said go home and practice sexy
faces in the mirror
like what what
how do you do a sexy face i'm like
trying to
do my lips and so i went back the next
day and i go
listen the only thing i can do is smile
that's all i know how to do i'm
like then just smile so i smiled and
then i got a phone call a week later
that's half said you're officially miss
october 1993 and i was like oh my god
this is so crazy and
how am i gonna tell my parents jesus
what month was it do you remember how
much time you had to figure this
scenario
i had i was told in february
and october you know was coming out
and uh i thought i was so clever because
in playboy they make you fill out this
you know the playboy sheet of like your
likes and dislikes and your
your sizes and i put where i'm from i
put
park ridge illinois just to try to throw
people off
like that would throw people like oh
yeah it's not the jenny mccarthy from
evergreen
it's the jenny mccarthy from park ridge
and so my my i took some of the money
and i paid off some of my college debt
and then i took the other part and i
sent my parents on a cruise the week the
issue was coming out
yes and now wait what did they pay you
they paid you
they paid twenty thousand dollars wow
you were excited about three grand
you're like that was easy
i mean it was crazy i was like oh my god
this is perfect i have enough money to
go to la to get there at least
wait and how did you explain to your
family how you
got money to do anything
i told them that i was i got a job
modeling for like
uh commercials i did start doing
conventions
like i was a hot dog at the convention
center or i was a cheerleader at the
convention center
those things were true i just said i got
paid a lot more than i did
so i sent them on a cruise and then
while they were on the cruise i wrote
each one of them letters separately
because mom
is different than dad and playboy had me
go to los angeles the day they were
coming home so i wasn't even gonna be
there mind you my
aunts who are nuns my uncles who are
priests were calling my house telling me
i'm gonna burn in hell forever because
it was on the news it was on the
freaking news this local girl from
chicago from prestigious catholic school
poses naked back then it was huge you
know it was a big scandal it's
still huge i mean it's still the girl
next door gets
naked i know well what's the lesson like
what's the lesson in it right because
like i always like to loop things around
because like
it's amazing amazing freaking stories
you have um
and you're so open which is amazing um
but what's the lesson
right there hadn't been something that
you took from it you're like okay this
i'm not gonna ever do again
and i'm gonna own this or i'm going to
from now on i'm going to
trust my intuition or whatever like what
what did you go
this is a big deal and here's what i'm
taking from it
what i it took from it is whatever you
fear
running towards it not away from it
like go with your intuition even if it
scares the [ __ ] out of you
even if it's going to upset
people around you that's fear
but and who knows i was terrified of
going to la and
making it or not making her failing and
my aunts and uncles condemning me to
hell
i was like you know what i'm just gonna
run towards it
i nothing to lose i've got a feeling
inside
this happened to work out the way it did
i'm just gonna run right towards this
fear
and thank god i did honestly and that's
what i've continued to do
in the course of my career is um
anything i'm nervous about i go okay
thank you emotional guidance system
thank you for alerting me that that's
what is what i should do
now mind you if i'm fearful of um
jumping off of a cliff that makes sense
of course you should be scared of that i
don't say then go jump off a cliff
it's more about like opportunities
because
a lot of people are scared to quit their
jobs and take a new
one yeah break up with their boyfriends
or girlfriends you know
because they're scared to be alone to me
that is a sign from emotional guidance
system that that's exactly what you're
supposed to do
run towards it tell me another story
where you ran towards it
oh god one that was like
a tough one like what's a tough one
a tough one was
oh there's a few of them my son when he
was diagnosed with autism
and he had seizures that he would he
actually wanted a cardiac arrest and
died in front of me
uh recovered obviously but um
i was i i was i dropped my
i mean that was the lowest of low any
mother would say the same thing i mean
he was blue
they started cpr um he had
75 more seizures that in the next two
days it was just
an awful time and
the doctors said to me you know there's
really nothing you can do
um the best thing you can do
is just maybe get him some you know
instructions some teachers
that can teach him how to maybe uh
put food in his mouth function function
because he's probably going to be
institutionalized institutionalized
so i was
obviously depressed and horrified by
that but
then i had this intuition of you know
there's got to be something else there's
got to be someone
offers hope someone so i
this is when online like just kind of
really started a little bit and i
love the long sounds that you hear like
i'm on so i found a small group of
parents doctors and scientists i mean
teeny tiny
yeah no one heard of them you know they
were like hiding
and said hope for recovery and
in the process of what they were
offering were
alternative things that were not
sanctioned
and it's scary because now i'm going to
use my kid as
a possible guinea pig to try to
save him and that's [ __ ] scary i'm
going to try stuff on him that we don't
know no one knows
works or not right and i had to make
that decision
of like take the safe road or take the
scary as
[ __ ] road and do everything you could
possibly do and i
dove in to the deep
end and when i say
i did everything this poor kid i was
rubbing spoons on them i had mormons
come over to do a prayer
i had like anything i could possibly
read like
injecting them with just detoxed and
you name it but
by the grace of god he uh he got better
he got better and he got better and he
got better and i was like
all right maybe this is another one of
my missions maybe this is the only
reason i
became famous is to actually help
mothers and dads and families
who might have a chance of their kid
getting a little bit better
and uh when i got that realization when
i kind of put that together
i literally felt an electric
bolt like came down from the heavens
and like i was sitting at the computer
like oh
my god like this is what i need to do
and um so i once i concentrate on
getting him better
then i spent the next three to five
years solely
touring the country going from city to
city sitting down with over half
a million moms face to face going okay
this is what you try this is what you
try it's not gonna work for everybody
but
kids can get better if you do this and
that and that and that
and uh i did that for like three to five
years before i
burned out i because emotionally i was
like
burning out i still of course am helping
people
but just it's not my it's not my nine to
five
well i mean you came from you know not
only
playboy but singled out and you know
like
this sort of fun sort of out there
you know personality and then here you
go into which your first book um
belly laughs right isn't that that was
why you were pregnant right i mean that
was
like i remember like every single
frigging mom had to get that book
they're like oh that's the
[ __ ] that's the real [ __ ] that happens
um
and and then after that with with
everything to do
with autism and with evan and with the
books and the truth like
you really i don't know to me
it really
built you as this whole person that's
not just
over here like you know
looking amazing and doing these things
that maybe not everyone's comfortable
with
and can do and then you're over here and
you're like oh wow
she's got content she has depth she has
intelligence
she has integrity um and she has
obviously faced some huge challenges so
like
i don't know for me and for me i was
like holy [ __ ] she's legit
like she's you know she's not just
singled out jenny
you know no you know when i look back on
it in hindsight and go
you know i'm grateful for this journey
because who knows i could have been
still
identified in that role that how
everyone perceived
me which is really easy to do in this
business you know
and it gave me um purpose and it was i
always
wanted to serve in some capacity and i
knew it wasn't just to be the
you know funny chick that farts and
picks her nose i'm like i'm way more
than that
so the fact that i knew i had a bigger
purpose to help serve
oh yeah you know you totally took the
conversation about vaccinations and
about autism
i honestly feel like you put it on the
map
yeah there were parents that came before
me but i was the first
any loudmouth that really you know sat
in oprah's chair
with her and went live and talked about
it for the first time and you know
still get [ __ ] about it i still get you
know
daily you know bombardments
oh yeah yeah yeah
but think if i give apartments about my
fake ponytail
you know what i mean it's like i learned
from
high school though
you know those are projections you know
it has nothing to do with me
i if i had their level of consciousness
that's how i would
react to you know if i had their
history and this goes for anybody and
everyone that's how i look at it
you know that's how i look at people
with matt who want to wear masks and
people who don't want to wear masks i go
if i lived
in their body and had their history
and lived their whole life that would be
my level of consciousness and that's how
i too would react and so it makes it so
much more peaceful
coming from that perspective for you to
achieve that that young i'm like you're
saying these things and i'm like
yeah the way that someone treats me has
a lot more to do with how
they feel about themselves than it does
with who i actually
am you know whether it's you know this
morning walking the dogs
in the forest and having people just
berate you for not having them on the
leash
and then i can see my mom reacting like
mom why do you even respond like that's
what they want from you their level of
consciousness is here
they're in a fierce state like just let
them they like imagine that their own
little
in their own little bubble of energy and
has nothing to do with me
like they want you to react to justify
their fear
and to play with it just
so how how did you get there though like
you're saying that you recognized this a
long time ago and i'm like yeah that was
like
this morning you know when i went to los
angeles
um when i left that day and i drove my
u-haul that only
would go 30 miles an hour which was fun
um
the first week i was there i went into
the psychic guy book shop
and i was like oh my god
oh cause in la there's all that stuff i
mean it's way more hippie stores
it's really hard to find hippie stuff in
chicago really hard
and so i walked in and i was like oh my
god books on astral projection
and and and near-death experiences and
consciousness and becoming your higher
self what does this mean so i was like
21
absorbing all of these books and this
information and having my
mind expand and losing my belief systems
that i just grew up with for 20 years um
and it was it was a magical time
because i was a clean slate and i was
like let me open up to
all the possibilities and
then i just became somewhat addicted to
like
self-help and um
consciousness and astrology
and i just i just love it i like i
literally watch probably
four to five hours a day of like
spiritual videos self-help videos so do
i
i mean youtube is basically like about
two years ago i stopped watching the
news
um at first it's kind of weird and you
feel uncomfortable and you're like you
wanna like i would normally just turn on
good morning america today show
something like that it was like
almost like a comfort to me and so at
first you're like oh shoot this is kind
of odd and anytime you're trying to make
a pattern change it's always
uncomfortable at first
and then i'm like what do i do so then i
was like i don't know i watch something
i'll get
i'll watch a video on something so then
i get my phone out
and then i just start searching for like
topics that are interesting to me and
it's not the first time i've used
youtube but
it was the first time that i started
using youtube as essentially
like my only means of education about
anything
right not about the world like just
about like reality and quantum mechan
quantum physics and metaphysics and
how the world works and you know
entities and aliens and
you know i mean just any consciousness
of course and like how we create our own
reality
and like i would that's my news so
that's what i watch i watch that all the
time
and then whatever my hot topic of the
time is i'm like deep diving into that
so
you know and of course it's so helpful
because it just populates your time your
your feed with everything that has to do
with whatever you just looked at so
the more you look the more you look
that's why when i talked to the first
time i was like oh my god we're going to
be
[ __ ] soul sisters because i don't
know anyone
that's like me except you who
watches as much as we do i mean it's
like almost it'd be funny to like
look at our history sometime and compare
it because it's like
i mean i mean i just i just had a
breakup you probably don't want to look
at my history right now
oh how are you doing by the way
oh well you know growing right
because yes from everything that
anything
that happens to you that is challenging
there is an opportunity to grow if you
choose it
right so for me i'm just i'm learning
about boundaries i'm learning about
you know um you know my own self-worth
and you know just also kind of how i
like to operate in my day
like how does my day look exact like
only me because i've never done that
and so my nature is to kind of fix and
you know help and you know be
accommodating and go with the flow
but you know you lose yourself a little
so i'm you know but anyway that's for
that's for that's for girl talking wine
exactly exactly
but it's so informative and you know
what i mean do you have a hot topic
you're checking like what do you feel
like you're looking up now what's
what's on what's at the top of the feed
for curiosity
it really depends on the weeks like um
you know three weeks ago or maybe a
month ago it was like
star seeds and light workers and uh
dimensions and the law of one the law of
one i'm really into
um do you know the law of one so there's
it's very uh confusing for you know
the way they speak it's basically um a
book that was
not a book you can listen to the audio
tapes of some uh
it was channeled by i think uh six
density beings
and um it's it was confusing
but i found a guy on youtube that i am
now
addicted to he's my latest binge
everything i'm like probably watched a
thousand
hours worth of his he breaks down
eckhart tolle the law of one
everything that we like outside of the
super ufo alien stuff but still love one
is still considered aliens
his name is aaron abke you should have
him on your show
um he's young he's like 27
and he he's every one of his videos i'm
like oh my god he speaks like us
like sometimes eckhart in the beginning
i was like is he speaking spanish i
don't really understand
what eckhart is saying but as
time went on i finally got the hang of
it but this guy
aaron apke i'm like oh my god i'm
totally addicted to i just had him on my
show too don't you wonder
how someone cause i feel like this is
something i've come across
too with looking up people on youtube is
that
there are some folks that are real
freaking young
that are enlightened like they have some
level of understanding for existence
and reality that's next level
natural almost like you don't get the
feeling like they even learned it like
they just
know it yeah i have this i have this
theory that
all these really like whether it be
nicola tesla
or albert einstein or you know
cartoli or any of these people that have
come through um
come through come through history that
we look at as being like
oh wow they were really a thought leader
like i actually
feel as though the trajectory of our
culture is
is is getting higher raising it rising
in consciousness
but these people that come in are
essentially i think
all just like these totally like
super intelligent enlightened aware
like they didn't forget everything when
they came into this life
but i i get that i feel like these
people that come in throughout history
aren't
actually like i feel like they're
special humans that
if you put them into 2000 and you know
2056 versus you know 1856 like they're
still going to be the same like
uber intelligent enlightened being i
feel like it's
like culture that's growing you know
rising in consciousness but these people
that come along are just brilliant and
like
you know maybe there's more and more and
so maybe starseed is kind of
you know something to look maybe but i'm
always you know
by these youngsters me too i'm on tick
tock on the dates it's tick-tock too
like the funny videos
um but there's also like because they
know i like spiritual stuff the
spiritual
like 20 year olds are speaking these
words of wisdom and i'm like oh my gosh
and i
believe the same thing i feel like
they're
we've humanity has gotten to like kind
of a crisis point
where all of these higher density beings
said you know what
let me go in there let's all go in there
and you know and kind of elevate
the consciousness of the planet and uh
light workers you can call them whatever
you want wanderers i've heard um
it's working i feel like the last you
know 30 years
there's definitely been a shift where 30
years ago you don't really hear about
near-death experiences mainstream
or any of the language reviews now
consciousness people be like what
did you get knocked out did you black
out is that what you mean by
consciousness
um but now today it's
it i definitely feel like even though
it's a mad time right now
chaos does create
you know elevated consciousness so
hopefully
these light workers
are you know actually light workers i
think they are
yeah wait but i really am curious what
you
think is going on right now like 2020 is
crazy right
and so you know just like you said there
can be obviously the good found in all
this and so
you know with all the destruction is a
rebuilding in a in a new beautiful way
but um what what the hell's going on
like if you go into your intuition and
go here's what's happening
i mean what i kind of
tap into is a moment in time
where we're given this opportunity to
ascend
if we choose to not only do we have the
time during quarantine
to notice behaviors get triggered by
behaviors
i do feel like we are we've entered
into a phase where we have the
opportunity
to fast track ascend right now
um whether that's a micro nova
that i've heard about that could be
happening um
but we are orbiting into this new kind
of galactic
energy i don't know if you've gone and
in that route on youtube yet
so the earth is literally rotating into
a new
part of the galaxy where the energies
are like
christ-like consciousness and this is
true it's on like
the nasa it's not just metaphysical but
moving into these
energies we're all going to feel it they
call it like end of time
madness and it literally it
everything your karma you feel memories
you feel triggers are much
higher and heightened and this is all to
kind of bring us
aware and to look at it and make changes
so even though the news you know is
showing the horrific things that are for
real going on
you know it's up to us and each of our
ourselves
to do that kind of inner work
i do feel that um as much as we
want to convince or teach everyone
around
us even not around us just anywhere on
social media
or your parents or you know even your
kids
you it really does start with yourself
like go
in word like work on your triggers work
on your emotional guidance system
because it's amazing how much compassion
you could actually find for an [ __ ]
karen
in your heart when you're doing the work
and
i'm sure you understand when i say
[ __ ] karen um but
you know which is the name they refer to
as people that
are you know losing their minds in
stores and
yelling at people but it's a it's
amazing
how your perspective can change and your
life can change
by going inward and doing the work on
things
that trigger you i mean i think yourself
yeah that's what they always say it
starts with you like every like
if everyone just did if everyone just
looked at themselves
and fixed themselves then everything
essentially is fixed immediately
right if we could all just do that it
takes a hell of a lot longer to go
convince people
teach people educate people you know
just start with yourself
but that's like it's hard right where do
you start and every
i mean i feel like even for myself you
look at your life and you look at who
you are and you think
oh i'm good i'm totally rational i make
good decisions i know the best way to do
everything
like you go i'm so normal i'm
sure it's their problem not mine so it's
almost just hard to even know
when it is you how do you know when it's
you
your triggers your triggers because like
i'll go like
well i feel pretty peaceful in my life
right now and
i'm actually working on i do take one
spiritual practice at a time so the one
i'm working on
right now is everyone is me
everyone is we're all god everyone is me
so everyone i interact with and i look
at
i'm like oh you're me experiencing life
through a different perspective and it's
it's
that's kind of a hard thing to work on
but i really think
by following your emotions your triggers
what makes you sad mad jealous angry
there's plenty to work on right there
you know so if you start to heal those
things
and to start to look into those things
it's amazing
how much not only does it raise your
consciousness but
lighter you feel happier you feel and
then the next time
something you know happens you notice
oh my gosh i'm not reacting i found that
space in between the emotions and the
reaction
and that is everything somebody
again starts with yourself what was the
most recent thing that you feel like
you've
healed or corrected or reprogrammed in
yourself
to not notice a trigger for
um i would say
the thing that kind of went oh that
really worked
was i was i've been working on that
you're me everyone i meet is myself
which is
really easy to do when you are like
people but now cut to
the person that is yelling at you
or calling you names or hurt you and
you're just like you want to be like
you know what [ __ ] you sorry i don't
think i swear
but you know you you want to explode
and i'm like okay how can i get someone
that's
an [ __ ] to me how do i look at them
as god or as myself
and trying and then it hit me
it hit me i immediately put my
son as that person
so this person that was rude
impatient meaned me i put my
son as that person and now i have
compassion
understanding because of course i would
have compassion for my son
if he was hurting and my heart
opened up i was like go bruh
so it's still a work in progress but
that's
what i'm working on right now especially
if like i'll have to go on social media
and someone would be like
and i go i noticed the first feeling
of me wanting to react and then i stop
and then i go okay
this person is my son and now i have
compassion
and then i go into if i had their level
of consciousness
and their life experiences i would be on
yelling at jenny mccarthy too
and it just brings me to peace
but that's beautiful i have
i when you mentioned that i remember
somebody saying
to imagine everyone as a child
just so you put you put evan in that
place to be that person
so that it can change the way you feel
and respond
but i've i've also heard someone say
imagine
everyone as a child like jenny or the
kid like if you said something me i'd
imagine you as like a little girl and
then you feel
empathy and you understand that that's
just like what they were taught
have you gotten honestly those those
triggers
that we have let's face it our core
trauma from childhood
i was just imagining have you gotten
into the childhood trauma thing yet
because that's hot hot hot button i mean
i just had a
whole conversation with my mom today and
i'm like
are you mad mom are you mad you know
like
talking about fixing triggers or you
know how to correct
you know certain programming she doesn't
like about herself and it's like
i could feel myself going to like i
could feel myself being a little preachy
in a way that like wants to help right
but yeah the childhood trauma thing is
real it is
real it is and if people just people are
really scared to go back
and look at theirs and i understand
you know um i did my own therapy
over years and years and years i've i've
i've gotten to know my inner child
really well
but it helps in relationships because if
if donnie gets
triggered by something that might be
small
i can really go that's baby donny that
didn't get
a b and c in his childhood and how do i
know that
because we've had those talks i know his
wounds
so he's done this too he's done oh yeah
oh yeah we both
have when we met up the first day i met
him i said
listen just so you know i'm into
self-help i really love it i'm into
byron katie i'm into echo totally so if
you want to go on this journey get ready
he was like i'm in so the whole
time we've been um on this
course together growing and learning
and kind of holding the light i call it
for one another
so um if one of us is caught up in our
ego or
we're not awake and we're triggered and
but the other one can remain present we
call it kind of holding light
so the one that's present and holding
the light
allows the space for the person to kind
of
get it out and it's amazing because when
you don't react
as the partner holding the light that
person is
able to have a full circle moment and
actually hear what they're saying
but they can't do that if we immediately
go what the hell are you talking about
i didn't do that then it starts with war
you know but um that's one thing that we
started our relationship right away
going let's
learn this together yeah that's not
quite helpful
that's fun we have to have both people
involved right it takes two to make a
relationship
work always one can't carry the weight
of it
right one can't carry the weight of it
and um
it's so good that you want to go on that
journey yeah
yeah exactly thank god thank god because
um like he said
one could only stand i think there so
long
and be a partner if right if the other
one doesn't want to grow i mean you can
you could buddha it out
and be a zen master and be like okay yes
okay yes okay yes
but um that's where self-love comes in
you know yeah
kind of like living a single life man i
mean if you're the only one that's just
kind of like
yes like i feel like it'd be like being
single instead of being in a partnership
where you help each other grow because
with the right
with the right person the opportunity is
there for your
biggest growth because they're you're
they're they're your most intense mirror
oh the best teacher they say and it
really is like i've learned a lot
out of relationships like found my voice
in past relationships because the
relationships were so bad
it was so bad that um i finally had to
learn to speak up because all i would do
was read my self-help books
and i'd be like okay the problem's in me
i've got to figure this out
and then i realized the biggest lesson
of all no i got to use my
voice i've got to communicate
and boom the light kind of that was the
biggest
i think wake up moment for me because
when i started to use my voice that's
when i
understood what self-love meant
because self-love always confused me i'm
like am i supposed to hug
myself is it masturbation what are we
talking about here
what is self love and um
and it's doing things that are good for
you for your growth
using your voice saying no to people who
might
ask too much of you sometimes and you
always go all right i'll help you move
all right i'll do this for you you know
no no then you become a martyr
you know you become a victim and a
martyr so um
that's that was one of the i think the
greatest tools
a horrible relationship gave me i've i'm
equally confused of what self-love kind
of meant like i love myself but
understanding that just like you said
that as well as you know for me learning
boundaries of just you know boundaries
of like
don't cross this line or like don't
punch me but like
speaking up for what it is that you want
and not letting someone
um take advantage of your kindness or
your
level of giving or whatever it may be is
to sort of say like
you know whether it be you know early on
in a relationship and you're the one
that's always going to see them be like
okay so a boundary is like i need equal
effort
so if you don't come see me or you might
not even have to say that you just let
the let the let the chips fall and you
go
guess that didn't work you know
right but those are those kinds of
boundaries so does donnie like aliens
too
i mean this is i feel like this is
important
i my god i mean i love talking about
aliens i mean i talk about it on my show
and they always make fun of me but i
don't care
because i don't care um he is now
educated i'll use that word he's
educated
in the ufo stuff um sometimes he'll send
me news clippings but he'll like read
something clippings like what am i from
the 40s
um he'll send me text messages of like
oh wow look at this pentagon just
announced that they're you know
announcing their thing so he he's
definitely
involved through via you know
by proxy but he's no big
huge oh my god let's go to a mountain to
go watch them where's
you know it's my dream trip
what was the what was that other movie
there was a movie that was done by
steven greer did you see the more
recently
yeah have you been summoning the aliens
because in the movie so if anyone hasn't
seen
it it's really good and it actually gets
to um
intention and creation and and it's not
just like aliens and something so out
there that it doesn't
resonate with you it gets to
more of like creating your reality and
asking for what you want and
part of it is like summoning the aliens
yeah i mean definitely one thing i loved
about this documentary is it combined
ufology with spiritual
and why they go together and why it kind
of opens doors for certain people
but stephen greer has an app and i got
his app
years ago um to summon aliens and
uh not i never did it i've never tried
to do
it i just was like oh cool app um but
then when he came on my radio show i was
like you know i have your app he's like
it's updated it's even better and people
in your neighborhood now
you can get together and do some
summonings of the aliens and i'm like
you know there's a place called e ceti
do you know what that is
e-c-e-t-i uh all caps you can look it up
it's a camp in forgot which state it is
uh maybe montana or something like that
but um
you go to this camp and it's a high
um vibrational kind of mountainous area
and they have daily ufo
sightings and you can go on their
website and youtube and
i just watched their live feed two
nights ago but you can see them
like come down and glow and they've got
pictures of
weird images and stuff i mean okay so
the you me and the whole scenario we
moved that
out there totally oh
i would i just told donnie i was like
can i please go to you said he's like
why don't i go
next week and he's like jenny there's a
cove it is happening i'm like but i
really want to go so bad he's like
listen you've got your whole life take
it easy
summon them from the backyard from now
and i'm like okay you're like but my
level of consciousness is not oriented
with fear
i'm not afraid of cloven
if i don't have a resonance of fear then
it can't get me
or the aliens can save me one of the two
right
what would you do i've thought about
this myself what would you do if there
was a real
alien encounter like i've it's crossed
my mind like what if you just see one
what if one approach what if one appears
what
what if one's in your bedroom what if
like have you ever like
run that through your mind of what that
would be like and what you would do
well i for sure have and i've also
wished
um and put intentions out there for only
the
high vibrational high density aliens
to show up so blue avians planed
whatever
as long as i'm high vibrational i'd be
like awesome then i'd be like then i try
to you know be telepathic with them
um i'm really most excited about
their technology like the technology
that
supposedly which someday they're going
to bring
but they have brought let's not fool
ourselves they have brought
um but i like the idea of the healing
technologies
that are coming which i
believe are here but they're just being
held back
there was something that popped up on
instagram and it was
um some old footage of this scientist
that had a
basket of some sort and it was like a
flying basket
and um so i'd sent it to a few of my
girlfriends and i was like
i literally had this dream about this
basket like
a year or two ago where it was like the
way that you traveled
interstellarly like the way you traveled
in space
was you'd get into this basket that
looked just like this video i'll forward
you the video
and you got into it and it was as if it
had its own force field
like energetic bubble that you could
travel anywhere
in like so fast in the universe and you
wouldn't get wind blown because of
course you're in your own little force
field right
like you have like this energetic bubble
around like
projecting out towards you that like
encompasses the little
basket and you go anywhere in the
universe that was a dream i had and then
i saw that video just yesterday in
florida's house
yeah i'll have to send oh my god this is
not so cool
have you dreamt of any aliens or
anything um
nah i don't really dream of aliens i
don't either i mean
i you know i keep wanting to consciously
know i'm astral projecting but i get as
far as like lucid dreaming where i can
like fly in my dreams and i'm in control
of my dreams but i'm like
i've met any aliens but what if
we're all just fragments of energy and
so
we see only what we've ever known to see
in our mind like we don't have
maybe that sort of creative awareness
for other or maybe we're just all the
same
right like if we're just kind of
fragments of energy maybe a human
is the same as a blue avian on the
astral plane in some kind of way
i don't know but then they say you can
take like ayahuasca and other plant
medicines and other hallucinogenics and
you can kind of like
get into them it is true
aliens damn it i know and and you know
it's also we're
you know energy and we're
vibrating at a different speed you know
they're
vibrating at another speed so as
more and more as we i think ascend yeah
and
you know have go higher up in the
densities
um we'll be able to see them
or communicate with them yeah so i mean
that would be like the ones that channel
right they can raise their frequency or
access a frequency that channels whether
it's abraham hicks you know like esther
hicks
channels you know source energy or
barbara
or renichik or something you know
there's there's plenty of them that
channel but they
tap into that frequency of of
of you know something else um
what do you this is an interesting
question because this kind of this was
actually probably the question for me
that led me down like that
really thrust me into the spiritual um
journey and curiosity was the question
what is god
when did you ask yourself that question
um
this is probably like probably 2016 or
17
probably when i was like what is god
that's my question
what is not who is and so the funny
thing is is when you ask people
they tend to answer who he is like
they don't answer from a from a what
standpoint
like what is god because he's clearly
not a dude sitting on a throne in the
sky right like he's not a guy with a
beard and
that's not right so what is he asking
what is my answer is god is love
god is love god is energy and
beautiful energetic light it only
knows love it wanted to experience
love so fragments of god
are sprinkled about those us being those
sprinkles to experience we're still
connected
to experience love and the only way you
can experience it is by having
you know things be polarized so you have
to have
you look at us on this planet a lot of
polarization but that's how you
know and experience it so that's how i
feel that we're
divinely connected to god but god is
all-knowing consciousness god is love
mm-hmm yeah i'm with you
it's a frequency and i feel like that's
why it's omnipresent
too is because it's just a frequency
like achievable
frequency or maybe not achievable i
actually wonder that i was telling my
mom that's this this morning and i'm
pretty sure it went over and no it went
over her head but
um because she told me that but um but
i wonder could you be a human and
experience
christ consciousness well
jesus did jesus was a
i guess apparently he's apparently
according to my sources everyone
he's um a fifth density being right now
experiencing
um fifth density so um you know we're
third fourth just to break it down first
density
is earth water fire you know
that kind of thing it's just being
second density are animals
your pets animals you see third density
that's
us as we move up we become lighter
more high vibrational um fifth
and fourth density is about love
learning
love and fifth is wisdom
and sixth is understanding with this
term or something
and then i apparently seven you
connect back to source or you go to the
next octave and then there's a whole
other scale
but it basically matches your chakras so
one through seven
yeah it's very interesting oh
i know did you learn about chakras
probably when i'm off for like five
hours so i know
i have no idea when to wrap this up but
maybe we'll skip chakras maybe we'll
maybe we'll maybe we'll get to um since
we're kind of on
consciousness and you know could you be
a human
um do you believe like what do you think
happens when we die
um well i do want to back up and i think
eckhart is living christ consciousness
right now
okay um what do i think happens
when we die i think that
we um go to
we're met with beings whether those be
our angels we call them or
old relatives the past and then we go
through a life review
and i'm only speaking about the
7 000 books i've read on this subject
and the 8 million hours of youtube
videos i've watched on it
but everyone um has consistently said
you go through a life review so you
watch
your life and you get to be each one of
those people that you affected so you
feel what it feels like i know so the
good bad and the ugly but you don't
judge yourself in a negative way you
come out of it like having
understanding compassion and a
knowingness
of why you were on this planet and what
you still
need to work on and then you're given
the choice you can go back
you can connect back with source um
or you can become a guide to people that
are still on the earth plane you can
you know say you know what i'm going to
go and help out um
and be of service that way that's what
i think happens until we move up the
densities and go
connect back with source god source
whatever you want to call it
consciousness
um so do you do you or don't you believe
in reincarnation
oh yeah okay oh yeah that's where i feel
like you have the choice to come back
and recycle with your family members
um if you want and you choose
your life you choose the lessons that
you want
so um i i don't think you're alone in
this i feel like there's
you know guides and and that you do have
a choice
everyone has a choice but i certainly
believe
in reincarnation and i and i don't
believe
there is a hell i don't think god
source all-knowing consciousness um
created a burning pit of flames for all
eternity
when we are here on this planet you know
i call it it was my son i call it an
earth school i go
this is earth school evan everything
that
you know any mistakes you're like i made
a mistake i go you know what you make
mistakes so you can decide
whether you want to be that person or do
it again
and that's earth school and we get to
come back
if we want to come to our school hey
maybe we want to go to venus school
maybe we want to go to a different
galaxy
so i think the choice is ours
so do you think in the life review you
willingly take the role
as essentially maybe the perpetrator
in in life maybe that you like let's say
you were
really let's say you stole a lot like
just as an example like you were
you stole like you you really were poor
like you were a bad
bad mean business person you stole a lot
of money do you think you come back as
someone that then has everything taken
away from them and is broken
totally do or do you think that you get
you you elect to do that or do you think
that that's your karma that comes back
and they go
so you're going to come back in this
life on the other side
do you think it's your choice or do you
think that it's a it's it's out of your
hands
i think it's your choice i think you
always have the choice and i think
in that place uh on the other side that
you are all knowing at that point
you see the bigger picture so i think
you um would certainly possibly choose
to come back
as the opposite of what you were to
experience it
i also believe that even if you choose a
different experience
you have karmic residue that you still
have to experience
based off of your other lifetimes
so residue like i feel like even if you
don't come back as the beggar or this
you know the perpetrator you um
still have karma that you have to
experience in whatever life you choose
to uh kind of balance yourself out do
you think you're going to get to come
back in a good or bad position next life
i don't know if i want to
i think i wanted to stop i want to i'm
like i am either i
i love the journey but i would really
like to be
in a a different density
i think a lot of us would at this point
like
i'd like to go just play a little bit in
galaxies
and who knows you know the way we're you
know spitting out technology and if they
have disclosure about ufos
maybe we'll you know in my son's
lifetime he'll get to go
visit some other places maybe that
basket that you dreamt about
will be a reality in our lifetime
well i'd like to play with you on
another on in another dimension for a
life because i've said the same thing
i'm like
you know i need a break i feel like i've
been really really really doing it
really doing it really being in the
middle of it really being in the [ __ ]
really uh it's gonna feel like i wanna
tap out
i'm tapping out oh careful dog might
bark um
i was like i think the next life i'm not
not a human next time
maybe just a guardian angel you know nah
i kind of want to go to like
another galaxy i'd like to check out you
know some distant
distant places um for a lifetime
let's do that together perhaps we
actually already
maybe we already actually did i think we
have
i think we have 100 because
my feelings toward you i was like i
love her like i
like i'm like oh my god i'm with you
with my neighbors we would be over
every single day talking to each other
you know what i mean so we definitely
have a connection of some sort and i'm
sure we'll find that out someday
well i can't wait to um
do some of your tours i can't wait to
seek out aliens with you
um to drink some wine to talk about
all of these facets of existence that
are just so
fascinating and mysterious like that is
my jam
and you and i both haven't in i'm gonna
just say
because i believe this is to be true
about you an insatiable mind when it
comes to
information and conversation about it
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today
i hope you enjoyed it if you like what
you heard today and you want to hear
more please click on the subscribe
button